another day another scandal for black
lives matter one of their radical
activists ready been charged with trying
to assassinate a man named greg
greenberg a democrat running for mayor
in louisville kentucky of course the
left jumped at the chance to blame the
attack on republicans
a former biden campaign staffer tweeting
insane lunatic attempts to assassinate
louisville mayoral candidate this is
what conspiratorial right-wing rhetoric
and guns everywhere gets us
i'm afraid this is going to get much
much worse
but of course the shooter wasn't a
right-wing lunatic he was a left-wing
lunatic quintes brown is a cop-hating
anti-gun activist who actually appeared
on joy reid's show in 2018 to talk about
guns listen
we want common sense gun reform and if
you're not going to give us that then
we're going to get everyone out here to
vote and we're going to vote you out of
office so if you want to keep your job
yeah then you know give us what we not
what we want but what we need
but that's not all he posed with al
sharpton at an event
that's
i take pictures with people too so you
never know but obama his foundation
called this shooter a rising face
in 2018.
they can really pick them
and if you thought a little
assassination attempt would cause blm to
cut ties with brown you'd be wrong blm
louisville sprung 100 g's and bail money
to get them out
why didn't they just pull that money
from blm's headquarters they have like
60 mil lying around right
oh i'm sorry it's still missing
but we have some good news
black lives matter has teamed up with a
group of people who are great at working
with shady cash
the clintons
minion moore a longtime ally and
confidant of bill and hillary
has been placed on blm's board of
directors to oversee the missing money
but that's not all
they've called in the fixer
you're
jimmy right this is your house sure is
i'm winston wolf
i solve problems good we got one so i
heard
the wolf himself
crooked hillary's top election lawyer
one of the democrats dirtiest dirty
tricksters mark elias
according to the washington examiner of
filing this month states blm's books are
in the care of the organization that's
located at the address of the elias law
group
and it's not just that one filing
multiple blm reports list as firm as one
of their addresses so
who exactly is mark elias here's a
reminder hillary's top election lawyer
the same guy who pushed the russia hoax
and was involved in the dossier saying
the russians hacked the dnc server but
wouldn't let the fbi see it
he's worked to undermine elections by
pushing for election laws to be loosened
right before the 2020 elections
he's deeply tied into soros money
making millions off democrat
gerrymandering trying to redraw
districts
he knows how to squirm lie and get what
he wants by any means necessary
so he'll fit right in at blm
joining me now project 21 co-chair and
author
horace cooper
horace there's something just so
tacky
and pathetic about the clintons swooping
in
when 60 million dollars is missing from
black lives matter
is anybody seeing how terrible this is
well the first observation i would make
is you go with mark elias
if apparently avenatti isn't available
whenever you're trying to take still
misrepresent uh resources you've got
some go-to people on the left side in
the legal
arena but the real tragedy is it's only
shows like yours that are even
paying attention to this abuse of the
charitable legal services option that's
called blm
what are they doing besides buying
million dollar mansions in this country
in canada and you know even out of the
north american region what's going on
and why doesn't the new york times care
well that's interesting because let's
look at why do you think the clinton
team took over the blm charity mired in
scandal and financial shenanigans do you
think it's to create allies in the black
movement do you think it's perhaps too
you're laughing you're laughing
i was gonna say do you think they
actually want to find the money it's
okay it's cash that's what i thought
cash is king and their goal and the
reason that they bring their powerful
influence to bear is that they see that
there are a lot of corporations
just like the new york times a lot of
corporations that donated that
apparently don't care that there's no
delivery wow
you are willing to put 20 30 50 60
million dollars on the table well of
course the clintons are interested if
you're not concerned about where this 60
million dollars can go
they certainly have some good ideas and
then they can double it they can and and
you know this blm story is disappearing
about as fast as the waukesha
killing you know boom
off the front pages like that well
i just want to say this really quick
i don't understand how so
many americans who are concerned about
crime are ignoring the fact that nearly
a dozen people were killed during the
blm promoted riots of 2020 and now we
have mr brown himself a
accused murderer or attempted murderer
and we're bailing him out
why would the clintons or anyone else
want to be associated with them if it's
not for the cash yeah i wonder how joy
feels you know one of the guests on our
shows is now
charged with attempted murder
hopefully no guest on jesse waters prime
time has been charged with attempted
murder
because i would be distancing myself
very quickly
real quick jesse i think she's i think
she's going to hire the fbi to
investigate how this guy an accused
killer got invited on her show that's
what she does when she does hate tweets
yeah that's true
it's a cover-up like always thank you
horace hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else